avec la signature du protocole de Kyoto
le 11 décembre 1997 pour la première
fois des pays industrialisés sont temps
de sur la réduction d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de membres de Greenpeace
n'ont pas hésité à escalader la Tour CN
afin d'y déployer une bannière
protestant contre le réchauffement de la
planète à l'époque des militants
écologistes dont Steven gilbaud
aujourd'hui ministre de l'Environnement
avait posé un geste d'éclat en
escaladant la tour océenne
le Canada ne ratifie l'accord qu'en 2002
pour s'en retirer 10 ans plus tard
officiellement de Kyoto faisait
d'ailleurs partie de la délégation
canadienne à Kyoto au Japon l'école au
granols que je suis il savait pas trop
quoi faire avec moi sur sa délégation
mais je vous dis sur l'ambassadeur il
faut vraiment proposer un paragraphe qui
nous permet de revoir en fonction de la
science les objectifs il se tournent
vers ces conseillers
ans plus tard le Canada ne respectait
aucune de ces cibles entre 2015 et 2019
les émissions du Canada ont même
augmenté de 723 à 730 méconnes
contrairement aux autres pays du G7 qui
ont vu une diminution de leur production
de GES durant la même période le Canada
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire
pour régler l'incohérence entre nos
politiques environnementales et nos
politiques économiques le professeur en
sciences de l'environnement considère
Kyoto comme un moment charnière dans la
lutte contre les réchauffements
climatiques a commencé des on pourrait
dire la fin des années 70 même le début
des années 80 ou les changements
climatiques sont passés d'une
problématique juste scientifique a
vraiment une problématique sociale et
politique là où Kyoto aurait échoué
selon lui ce ne serait de ne pas avoir
inclus des pays émergents comme la Chine
et l'Inde en plus des États-Unis qui
produisent maintenant 65% des émissions
de effet de serre sur la planète ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal